Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you.
You can hear from the breathing and the background.
I usually do not have guests.
That's not something that I do,
but every once in a while I get a maniac in here.
Somebody who's fucking raring to go.
You might recognize this guy from his own fucking chest.
This man could talk about sports.
Seek and talk about the hip hop and the rap.
He can talk about the real housewives.
He's an actor.
He's a director.
He's out of breath.
Ladies and gentleman,
he's a,
he's one of the biggest Boston sports fans I've ever met.
Welcome back to the podcast,
your friend and mine.
Mr. Michael Rappaport.
Glad to be here,
Bill Burr.
How are you feeling man,
I wish I could.
Uh,
I had the words,
the words,
I mean shipped to paint a picture of what,
what,
what's going on here?
Like we're sitting on our couch or your couch here.
Here in your crib.
We both have on half see socks as he sucks.
I went white.
You went black shorts.
Yup.
Almost similar shorts but different color coordination and it's like this is,
this is a sad fucking sight for sore eyes were probably two of the most
undesirable white men in a,
in Hollywood.
That's real shit.
Maybe in the country,
like if,
if someone came in like soil,
like what?
This looks sad fucking site.
You told any woman you marry a white guy 15 years in,
this is what you're going to have.
He like,
he'd be like the worst thing for white people ever.
Like just across the board.
Like the picture of of me and bill burr with half see socks on.
But dude,
I'm barely covering the ankle.
I got on the Chrissy Everett,
you,
you got on,
you got on headphones.
I mean this is a sorry fucking site,
but I'm happy to be on the pod.
I know you requested to come on.
You seemed like you had some things that you needed to get off your chest.
Now this,
this,
you know,
for people who aren't,
aren't in your world or my world.
Yes.
Maybe just passing by on the Internet.
Yes,
I am from the Boston area and I support,
you know,
we have 14 so we just need one in each sport to win a championship.
You guys in New York needs like what 15 three,
four yes.
Well for each sport.
For each sport.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Exactly.
And then when things come Greensboro.
Yeah,
we'll steal them from jersey.
We bring me on Brooklyn,
half of Lids.
It's just New York teams.
Yeah,
it's,
it's not a problem.
I notice on your computer you have your,
your facetime camera covering ups.
Do you think so I do that on,
I'd do that on the TV.
I do it on everything.
I would do it.
No one's looking,
you know that no one's like no one's shit.
Like if people were looking they wouldn't be looking.
That's not true.
You think they're looking for you?
Oh,
what was,
I forget who it was.
Somebody with the TV kind of got busted.
So what are you doing in here that needs to be covered up?
Just like in your general general,
like day in and day out because well,
the laptop becomes like this on video camera.
So what if I'm here?
What if I'm on the couch and all of a sudden my wife comes and we started
banging and there's some guy at Yahoo fucking rubbing one out with his lab coat
on.
I mean,
I should at least get some money.
Do Amateur Porn.
No,
now you have a beautiful,
or if I watch porn,
I don't want to say to somebody seen me going like rubbing one out,
but you in a porno.
I don't think anyone's going to be able to get me in a porno.
Just,
just footage of me rubbing one out.
I don't need that out there.
I don't,
I that we're trying to go Disney.
I hear,
I'm trying to hit on that chair.
I hear you.
Um Oh,
it's all creepy.
But they still can like,
you know,
so you keep the tape on for security measures.
I,
I hear,
I primarily do it too.
I hear you.
So this is the thing.
If that fucking thing,
I think they live in the fucking the future,
right?
Look,
look,
look at how much shit I can store on this fucking and who the fuck am I?
Right.
And I'm just,
you don't know nothing.
I'm just a regular freckled cunt walking down the street.
That's it.
Just one of many,
one of many.
One of many things special on dodging the sun.
That's it.
Going from palm tree,
the palm tree out here.
I mean fuck man.
Wait,
who's got whiter legs?
I got it.
You're not scared of the sun the way I am.
I'm fascinated by that.
I was like,
Yo,
I mean you should be the spokes.
You should have like a son,
like a Sun Tan sun,
a sunblock,
sponsorship like you're fucking white and I'm super white,
but like you matched the wall color in here.
I don't go out in the sun.
I mean I like with my dog,
I'll get a little bit of a farmer's Freckleton sorry,
did I knock this over?
Yeah,
she said he's in broken.
No,
no,
it's fine.
Leave it on the floor.
Leave it on the shore.
Yeah,
just looking on the phone.
You you've done quite enough of right.
Sorry.
All right,
well listen,
let's bring it out to the people.
Let's tell the people what happened.
I saw you at a,
we were at a very big fancy Hollywood party the other night,
but low key.
It's like,
to me that party is a low key Hollywood party because it's a private party with
a lot of cool,
interesting sort of different sort of La show business people.
But I've,
I've gone to that party three or four times and actually the last time I
actually went out was at this party.
I've never been to it every time.
Every year I'm always on the road.
Right.
But I had,
I made it this year.
Yeah,
it's a good towards having a great time.
And then you showed up and,
and this is about 1145 on a Saturday.
And before I even was able to give you five,
we were like 20 feet away.
You say what?
To me now this is the God's honest truth.
I want to make sure we're on the same page here.
We was pretty buzzed,
but I believe sitting dude,
Bill Belicheck,
if he wins or had,
he already won,
I already won.
Greatest of all time.
That's not what you started with tonight.
I remember exactly what you said because I was about 25 to 30 feet away.
You said this is before.
How you doing Mike?
Before I,
where's your wife before?
What's up?
Good to see you for 25 to 30 feet away.
Three and,
oh motherfucker.
Three in fucking old.
And then you went on the bill Bellacheck right?
And then I said to,
and then I said to you,
I want the new way in.
And you said this is the old system.
It's so foolish.
That's where you're not right.
And you're now I want to,
I am here to explain this to you.
Bill burr not correct you when you're done,
check this out.
I want them to go for no.
Okay.
And what I really want to happen because I knit,
but not for any reason.
No.
Ooh,
careful.
Just as good as talk radio,
which you in there.
But you buffalo wild wings.
Fucking let me hasten to deal order and Jackie,
let me tell you my point of view.
I want them to go for no and then lose the first game back with Tommy and that
will,
you guys will be all fucked up.
Our will.
We will be all bent out of shape.
Then sort of create a cough.
Then if they look,
what if they lost two in a row with Tommy and Garappolo sitting on there and
what does that mean?
I'm just saying,
damn,
that's win super bowls he got to us or how,
let's see if,
let's see the pressure.
Has He know the Patriots not deal with facts.
Crazy look fancy,
right?
Cheesy.
Exactly.
If we stay right here in the present,
yes.
Three nor his fucking hall of fame career.
Absolutely were like,
who is this guy?
Is it,
is it?
Is it Frank Brady?
What's his name?
Tommy.
Let's stay in the present too.
We don't even know this guy's name then.
Then I could be,
who the fuck is this guy that just fucking brought in?
Oh No,
no,
no.
Then I can get to where you're at making it seem like I don't think Tom Brady is
great.
That's what I wanted to,
I come here to tell you I am going to try get what you're saying.
I get what you're saying.
You're just saying all you want is,
is some Dan Shaughnessy horseshit cause that's the only Chinese man.
So what are you worried about them but totally overwhelmed.
I honestly,
what are you worried about?
I asked you this arrest twice.
I know that.
Um,
but I,
I gotta be honest with you.
My,
you're like one of the only uncool giant fans I've ever met.
John Fans never talked shit.
They don't need to,
we don't need a tool.
Yeah,
but you do.
But I,
cause you know what it is sadness and you know there's,
it's a sad,
sad,
I'm trying to say this.
I know that this is a heavily Boston like your,
your,
your core core people.
You or your worldwide,
you're fucking worldwide.
You went on a copy toward Cape Man.
Yo,
you went on a comedy tour worldwide.
That's crazy to me.
That's crazy to me because it's like that,
that comedy,
I know it happens,
but I think that I'm so fascinated and respect that that comedy can translate
worldwide.
No,
it's all English,
but I think that's fucking does a lot of your worldwide,
you're worldwide a freckle concept.
Yes.
We're around the globe.
But your essence is a Boston fuck true.
We rendered Yestermorrow yeah,
right or wrong barrier insult and then try to run away from it.
They were boss to fuck true.
Ooh.
Did right or wrong,
just called me a postie.
You bought Boston.
Fuck.
Correct.
So,
so no,
I'm not,
you're not.
You're born and raised in,
I'm from the suburbs,
but it's an avenue expense.
You know,
they only time I was in Boston was when we first met doing um,
the heat,
the heat.
That was the first and only time I've ever been in Boston.
And you know her Boston,
thanks you for that.
They had enough.
They're like,
that's all you're going to get.
No,
dude,
this is the thing.
What happened was nobody knew shit about Boston.
And then goodwill hunting comes out and then everybody thinks that you have
anybody from,
from Boston.
Anybody from Massachusetts is from southeast still cars.
Do you like apples and you're good at math?
It was just a fun,
it was just a fucking movie.
I'm supposed to fucking movie.
I was,
I always say ever since that movie out.
All right.
I just
cause like new kids on the block then puts you on the map.
What do you mean?
Like the group new kids on the block.
Like new kids on the block.
How boy band.
Yeah.
I'm saying you guys weren't proud of new kids on the black.
No,
I must say when we were proud of,
when we were happy,
some local kids made it put like,
yeah,
boy band does not put a city on the map.
I'm just saying they weren't,
you know,
why does run running the table fucking every championship with just four teams.
But the thing that I want to acknowledge and I want you,
I want to try to get to,
I want you to see,
I love that you said that you've never been to Boston.
I haven't only that one time.
Can I tell you that's why I went over.
You say Boston has this inferiority complex to New York in sports and I just can
I just finish please sir.
Okay.
It's for nobody knows shit about New York and Boston unless you've been there.
I remember when I first moved there,
this is how little we knew despite how much we hated the Yankees.
And it was always just the Yankees.
It wasn't really a jets.
Jazz was none of that horse shit.
Right.
Um,
and even when we lost to the mets,
it wasn't like the fucking,
and we,
we've met them one time and it was more,
there was no rivalry.
It was bill Buckner.
Folks happens.
And why did you have Calvin Shrine?
You know,
I'm not a baseball guy.
Well,
let me finish.
Let me finish.
Which guys,
Bill Buckler let me finish this.
Let me finish this.
All right.
Yeah.
To do this.
How can you like think that that's still bugs me.
I watched that highlight now when I laugh.
Which one?
The Buckner what?
Which one is that?
I don't,
you know,
I'm not a baseball games.
Six Games,
six.
I'll walk you through it.
Okay.
What happens?
A ground ball went down the fucking between his legs.
I could stopped it with my parents and bill Buckner played for the red sox.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
You know I,
I know basketball,
no football.
Baseball.
So sad.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
Go ahead.
Are you still giving me shit about the fact that Oh four happen and we won three
world series since then?
No,
I was just trying to get more sacks.
Stanley Cup championship and an NBA champ.
You don't want you to do right now.
You're wearing your high school jacket going.
Remember 86 I can't,
I get confused about baseball.
They're halfway there.
Come on dude.
That's fucking,
that was 30 years ago.
They focus,
they focus on the finish.
This story that you were telling me,
I am focused.
I know what to tell him ahead.
Go ahead.
I just wanted to get clear on Buckner cause some people you said they might be
passing to pay,
they might not know the reference.
They might know the ref now.
Crazy legs.
Johnson fumble the ball for the,
uh,
the Ohio.
Who gives a fuck in 1930.
I mean,
I'm sure if the people who live in the Columbus area still devastated.
Okay,
go ahead.
You're ready.
Go ahead.
And I'm,
yeah,
so when I moved to New York,
yes.
Oh,
I told him you would live in New York.
I moved there.
Yeah.
And my buddy goes,
he says to me,
where do you live in New York?
And I said,
I live on a 97th,
and third.
And he just goes,
do what's,
what's with all the numbers down there?
Like why are all state's number like he didn't know fucking anything about like
we don't know,
like that whole inferiority complex.
You guys do this now it's,
it's manufactured by ESPN.
I understand that.
You want us to,
you want us to,
nobody gives a shit about me.
You only gives a shit about New Yorkers.
New Yorkers.
Listen,
listen guys,
all fucking you guys,
even though the Tad's steaks and you get yourself a slice and you do your sad
stakes in a slice it,
you do your in Times Square,
right?
One of the,
one of the worst fucking places in America.
Absolutely.
Every hip hop video they're in,
they're like,
we made it the fucking m and m store in Times Square is a fucking wreck.
Every city must have like Hollywood boulevard is the same thing.
Yeah,
but,
but what do you guys have that similar cheers?
What do you mean cheers?
The Bar Yours and you're going like a whole neighborhood.
You got cheers.
Yeah,
because boss,
you see him.
You see what I'm saying though?
Giant cheesy area.
Yeah,
but it's,
it's for the,
you know,
the betterment of the city.
It's called midtown.
But you guys have one street where this happens.
Just trying to get a map in my head cause I did not.
I'll,
I'll get,
yeah,
and everything else is authentic.
We don't waste it with all that other shit.
I mean,
yeah,
you can go,
you can put on a Paul revere hat and walked down the freeway.
Do you want to?
But other than that,
it's a bunch of great bars and people can actually talk sports,
good food,
tremendous food.
Um,
a bunch of characters out there.
Everybody's fucking funny up there.
There's really not a,
in sports,
you weren't into sports.
You,
you would actually love Boston.
When I was there for the two or three weeks while we were working together.
I liked it.
Good Restaurants,
nice people.
Easy to get around,
a maneuverable.
Um,
that's the same thing,
but we'll give it to you,
you know,
maneuverable.
You know,
like you could take a train,
you could like,
you could the,
there's the train,
right?
Yeah,
I would,
I would have just said good public transportation.
The bus,
right.
You could take cabs.
There's Uber's,
I did all of it.
You could walk.
I walked,
I got lost.
What?
You were in a city and you took advantage of it.
I took a village.
It was a good city.
It's a good city.
But there is that sort of the reason that sort of like,
you know lesser than sort of feeling that you guys have one spoiled a lot of
games.
What do you like?
Like the lesson comes up when you guys are three.
I like that fucking chick who never has a boyfriend and then goes like,
you know what guys are just intimidated by me.
They can't handle high,
Blah Blah Blah and you want to be like lady.
Do you ever think that maybe you kind of cut?
No,
that's hilarious.
You're walking around like ordering a sandwich and you just felt like as they
were making the sandwich that they was sitting there thinking inferior thoughts
to New York City.
Do you really this sport,
that's one of the most self centered thing anymore.
It's 1130 that door anymore.
1130 at night.
Why are you screaming at me?
Three and eight oh three and I mean I'll tell you why.
Your wife was like,
she walked away and like see,
everybody's embarrassed.
People are nervous.
You got a shaved head and people are freaking out.
Look at your,
now you're exaggerating.
I mean a little bit like three and old like,
Yo,
I'm fucking whacked out of my tree and you're talking to me about three and I'm
trying to let,
let me,
let me shake your hand.
Burn like that's what I'm saying.
Like I know you three are no,
I know Bella check is fantastic.
I know Brady's coming back to you right now.
No,
I bought the inferiority complex.
Let me,
no,
it has to do with you during this three in o streak.
Constantly shitting on Tom Brady.
Constant Shit.
So I was just rubbing in your face.
The set.
Let me ask you a question.
If you walked into that party and we were all in three,
ha ha ha.
You're going to tell me you would have said hello.
I love you because you're actually,
you'll actually fucking,
you'll go with if I get you with a good no,
I got to acknowledge your fans because we made bet that hasn't been
dealt with.
Cause I've gotten,
I've gotten a lot is made to,
you still owe me a dinner for the NBA finals?
No,
just one bet you NBA finals.
You still owe me.
I know,
but I want to acknowledge it because I got your fans a few times a day.
Did you fucking pay Bill Bell?
Berber his bet.
Have you taken burnout?
This is on Twitter and you know,
I don't mind I tweed Blah Blah,
blah,
blah.
But I'm getting like a sense,
I want to acknowledge that it hasn't happened,
but it's,
would you say it's a scheduling issue?
Uh,
yeah.
I would definitely say it's a scam.
You're traveling.
I'm traveling.
You're moving,
you're grooving.
You're overseas.
How maneuverable you on buses?
On subways.
You were in Greece?
No,
I was in Ireland.
Didn't you tell me you were in Greece?
Italy.
Yeah,
on a beach.
You're on the beach.
They can roam.
Yeah,
but I had a giant umbrella.
But I mean,
we're like,
what was that like?
I've never been like,
I've been,
I've been to Rome and I've been to Venice,
but I'd never been to the beaches of Italy.
So it was,
what was that trip like?
The Amalfi coast?
It was,
it was beautiful.
It's extremely touristy.
The food isn't as good as it is.
And when I was in Rome,
when,
yeah,
it was,
I was in Rome.
I couldn't miss when I was,
it's incredible.
When I was on the Amalfi coast,
like I had to ask around.
I mean,
I'm going to look,
I had the best eggplant parm or Sean I've ever had in my life when I was there.
Granted,
I didn't order it in Rome,
but in Raam,
dude,
I just couldn't fucking miss missing a diner and Rome.
People go,
you went to Rome,
you should go to Florence,
you should go to Venice.
She should go to Milan and I'll,
I'll look fucking tweets.
I'm going to get now everybody,
like everybody on the Internet and whatever.
You did this the wrong fucking thing to do.
You know why you're right.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
I can bullshit.
You cannot say a Rome,
Italy.
You Fuck,
you're an asshole.
How dare you?
Anything you say every single thing you say it's,
it's literally like you,
you can't,
unless it's fact checked.
But I like it though,
cause it's a great,
like,
it reminds me a litmus test.
Hey,
it's just,
you just can't fucking like,
I actually had a lot of comics,
uh,
you know,
I'll run into at this point because I've been doing it so long.
I'm the fucking old guy,
man.
I'm 48 now.
So like a lot,
most of them that I talked to her at least 10 years younger than me.
Right.
Cause uh,
you know,
most guys my age at this point of raw,
either mogul,
so they write and substitute teachers.
Right?
Right.
There's very few of us still doing comedy clubs.
So
they'll come up to me and I'll be like,
yeah,
you know,
I just want to see,
the other day this comic said Blah,
blah,
blah.
And they said to me,
and I always want to say like,
why the fuck would you listen to some negative cut like that?
But then I always go back to like,
oh cause I did,
I did when I was where you're at in the fucking business soap.
Right.
Um,
I kinda lets,
one thing I do like about Twitter is I,
when I actually read them,
like I used to respond like sports things,
I'll go back and forth cause that's fun.
But when there's any of that shit,
like I was offended or uh,
you know this facts checking horse shit on my fucking fact check all of that.
I'll either laugh or just kind of glance at it,
scroll by it or whatever.
But like back in the day,
like that shit with like a,
that would bug me.
Like if somebody really came at me yet,
you still really bother me.
And I had to develop a whole nother like,
Oh internet,
I need to have the wall up for the Internet.
You have to.
Yeah.
Cause the first time somebody really got me was back the my space days,
you know,
and like I,
I had the wall up if I was on stage in a comedy club and now I'm just sitting at
home eating a piece of toast your guards down and somebody hit me fucking both
barrels.
Dude,
I can't even remember what the fuck they said.
But I still remember the feeling I had to go for a walk and I was with Nia
still.
And uh,
she said to me,
um,
she goes in,
she basically said,
you're going to let that fuck you shouldn't read those things.
Look at this,
this could you just let this fucking guy you don't even know,
just ruined like an hour your life.
And,
uh,
it still took me an hour to come down.
I was just like,
you know what?
You're right.
This is stupid.
So now when I read them,
uh,
I just,
I laughed them off.
Unless it's sports sports,
I will go back and forth on.
Yeah.
I,
it's a,
it's a new frontier with,
with,
with the,
with the Twitter and,
and,
and you know,
if you have any sort of pump all the way with the Twitter,
no,
it's fucking crazy,
man.
You can't say Facebook.
Are you on the Facebook to the member of my space?
That was like 15,
16 years ago.
Right now.
I love this.
Uh,
you know,
when people book a job now,
Comedians book a job and then they jump on your Twitter and then they scroll
back.
Something recently got a job and they scrolled back on this person's Twitter.
You know,
they'd been on Twitter for like five fucking years,
10,000 tweets to tweets.
Oh,
about about something they said bad.
They didn't even say it bad.
It was a joke.
Right?
It was a Joe,
right.
Making fun of themselves.
They take it out of contract,
blah,
blah.
Bullshit.
Oh yeah.
Well yeah,
yeah.
All in those people who do it.
It's like,
Hey,
can I listen to your voicemails for the last month?
And I read all your texts.
We'll go through all of them shits to find and they have to read each and every
one to find one.
That's not good.
God forbid anything good.
All they're trying to do with shifts.
Cause it's just,
it's clickbait.
And then people will go on it and then all of a sudden like,
but I,
I,
what's the greatest?
The networks now don't seem to respond to it.
No,
they don't.
Which is great cause everybody's got some shit on there.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Mine.
My mind's horrendous.
My minds.
I think it's better to have a horrendous one rather than like butterflies and
flowers and then a couple of horrendous ones.
Right.
Then it's like what the fuck?
But if you just come in with the mean the whole time,
right then they're like,
yeah it,
there's nothing,
there's nothing new.
Like I don't think with you or me.
That should be your apology.
I tweet something like that every day.
Yeah.
What the fuck?
Where you bent?
Yeah.
And I don't care.
You're all of a sudden you're follow me.
Welcome to the fucking party.
So what's up?
What's up with you man?
So do you finish you,
you finished the second season of your show?
Yup.
Done or no?
We finished writing it.
So now it's,
it's all the punch up and the editing and all that type of stuff.
But you didn't do the voiceovers like [inaudible] I know it's not shot cause you
don't shoot it,
but did you record it?
Yeah.
It's all recorded.
And,
and,
and when,
when,
when is the second season of,
of,
of a coming out?
We're looking like may of next year.
It takes that long.
Well,
the thing about it was this was our first season,
so they had to see how we were going to do,
right.
So now like now that we're doing well and they're like,
and what's second season looks like?
We're already talking about the third season so they won't be as big.
Ah,
a a gap.
So it was one of the,
see I only gave me six.
Right.
And the reason they only gave me six I think was because when I went to pitch a
cartoon at that time,
no comedian was doing a cartoon.
Right.
Louie Anderson did one,
uh,
what's his face there?
Uh,
you know,
I'll be back to bill Cosby.
Yay.
Now.
But they all fuck every,
like,
it's not like Howie Mendell.
There's a bunch of people that have done like,
comedians don't just as of right now,
no one was doing one.
Right.
So they were expecting me I guess to come in and try to do my version of Louie
on my version of Marin and I just looked at those shows is a huge fan going,
I'm not going to fucking do this better than them so I'm going to be like the
third string quarterback holding the clipboard.
Right?
Like I'm not gonna fucking be better than Louis show and I'm not going to
fucking self examine myself.
Like tie the podcast in and all that shit.
Marin's already doing that.
Right.
It's just like I just felt like I didn't see any wiggle room between those two
shows.
Were those two shows like because of the success of looting,
because it's sex success of Marin,
you consciously said I need to do a like a cartoon.
Like Oh,
I had this idea,
I had this idea way back in oh nine and I pitched it to comedy central and I
wanted to do them is five minute vignettes of just crazy shit from my childhood
and they were just like,
well you know,
so and so just did a cartoon.
It was another comedian.
I'm not going to say his name right and it didn't do well and I wanted to be
like,
well,
you know,
Warner brothers did one with the bunny and that went did pretty well.
People don't like animation,
so they just kept getting kicked to the curb.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
I had a couple of one camera things.
I tried to do something with the always sunny guys,
which I could still can't believe that one didn't get picked up and they just
weren't getting picked up.
So I had this sort of,
this was the fun one,
right.
And I,
through Steve Byrne,
I met Vince Vaughn wild west.
They liked it.
Then they brought on the Great Mike Price from the Simpsons and uh,
then it,
then we pitched it around town and everybody was looking at us like,
who are these old guys pitching this fucking cartoon from the early Seventies.
Right,
right.
Then we went to adult swim was fucking hilarious.
Like the guy we were pitching too.
We were all at least like 15 to 20 years older than 10.
10.
The guy that was alive in 1972 you have a tight purple shirt on or a pink?
No,
he was a cool guy.
He was a cool guy.
He was just a young guy.
So it's just kind of like,
it would be like if me and the eighties or early nineties,
if someone came in who said,
okay,
the show takes place in 1961.
Do you remember when Blah Blah Blah.
We were talking about that when they used to spray for mosquitoes and all that
and this,
which is funny now that's coming back with the whatever that fucking virus is.
It Equiline known that equal.
I uh,
let's your Breton to Zeke,
you,
what is it called?
Zika.
Ezekiel Elliott.
Zika,
jumbo.
Elliot.
Um,
anyways,
so uh,
yeah,
so just kind of came bawling get,
so then nobody picked it up.
And then Vince was the guy who said,
well,
let's just go on Netflix too.
He was in the pitch meetings.
That's cool.
We'll do.
That's why it got sold because then I just went over to Netflix.
So good.
I'm a fucking no name comic.
Want to do a [inaudible] too?
And they'd be like,
yeah,
that's cool.
But I think they were thinking go fuck yourself.
And then they look to the left and like that's an alias movie star and he
believes in this.
So then I think they were just like,
we'll give you six,
right?
We'll give you six.
We see how they do.
And then fortunately for us,
while we were doing that,
bojack horseman came out and it blew up.
Right.
That one's right.
Oh,
it's doing great.
So show is that um,
that's Aaron Paul.
Oh,
right,
right.
I met the guy the other day and one of those things,
a great guy too.
My apologies.
So many fucking people in this business for so many fucking people.
They uh,
I loved.
You know what?
My favorite part of bojack horseman is just so fucking nuts.
I love his house.
I haven't seen his house as the shit is it?
It's Keith got the view.
He's got the fucking pool.
I got to watch it sits like I let every time I watch that show,
as much as I love all the shit they do it,
he was like,
you know,
former sitcoms star,
he,
he did like a too close for comfort kind of show and he's past his fucking
prime.
He's trying to get his career going again.
He does coke and like buddy,
I what I love is he has no shame.
And this is the animated.
Yeah.
What I love is he watches old episodes of his show and has no shame.
Right.
And it looks at them how great they are.
Ain't,
and he just goes around.
That's fucking funny.
Yeah.
And like you,
you see like some sometimes like he'll go out until like a restaurant or
something,
a Hollywood restaurant.
You're kind of like all that kind of seems like that place.
Like you know those old referencing places.
Yeah.
That's cool.
But do you watch it?
Cause they have it in the opening,
the opening credits of the shit and I fucking love his house.
I got to check that show out.
If bojack's horse horseman's house went up for sale,
I would definitely,
I would go to the open house,
the act,
you know what I mean?
And Bullshit.
Like he could afford it.
How many,
how many,
uh,
episodes you do doing in the second season?
Two.
You did 10.
And then what about third season?
10.
Is it a fucking grind to do this shit?
Um,
yeah,
sometimes it is.
It's,
it's more like,
uh,
it's,
it's uh,
it's one of those things when it's,
when it's going good,
right?
It's,
it seems like easy now.
Some of the most fun,
like we're in the writer's room and somebody comes up with something cool and
everybody's pitching on it.
We're all laughing our ass off and you know,
it's Netflix,
so it's not like you got to worry,
you just go ahead and put it in.
But um,
when,
when it's not working and all that,
all those industry words start coming out.
This isn't tracking and I think we earned this,
right.
This isn't our show,
This is in the tones in our,
in our Palette.
Right.
And all of that shit.
When that starts coming out and then it's,
it's already like fucking,
you know,
late in the day and you're going to stay late and then spitting and then you're
gonna come back.
I'll tell you one thing I've really,
I always had respectful,
but I really have way,
way,
way more respect now for is uh,
like nobody works harder than you show runners probably work the hardest.
And then writers.
Yeah.
And to listen to,
to writers,
man,
they fucking tell these horror stories like,
of,
of like Comedians,
all you tell the stories,
the story,
Shabaab,
they tell the stories.
It's like,
dude,
when you get a showrunner who's unhappily married or just doesn't like his or
her life,
it's just like you're never going home cause they're on top.
They don't want to leave.
They're waiting for their wife on the show runner to go to sleep boss.
Yeah.
And they'll just keep going over it and over it and they'll come up with shit to
do,
do.
And these fucking people will stay there till two in the morning.
They,
they're literally like Iceland and this guy a long time ago.
And uh,
he was unhappily married and he used to tell this hilarious story how he would
go out drinking and then he would drive past his house and if the light was
still on,
you would keep
driving.
Fuck
that.
Christ,
I was already afraid enough.
There was Anthony [inaudible]
told that story.
I was already afraid,
afraid enough to get married.
And then he told that story and I don't know what it was.
It was so vivid.
For some reason,
I pictured one of the houses that I grew up in whenever I pictured him telling
that story,
it's me and I'm driving by looking at what was the family room living,
a silhouette of them waking.
Yeah.
Just like,
you know,
as,
that's one of those things where he's just like,
Jesus Christ.
At some point you gotta be,
and he'd be like a beer.
Fuck it.
When I had my first son,
I was so sleep deprived.
I would leave the house to sleep in my car on the street.
Like I had parked my car in a shady thing and I had a big navigator and I
literally would like,
I'd have like a little pillow or like a sweatshirt.
And how would you just tell your wife he had somewhere and I got shit to do.
I got a meeting or whatever and I probably most likely would,
but then I would fucking,
or I leave three hours early or late,
you know,
like my meeting will be a 10 and they would come home just to sleep in the car.
Cause I was the first kid I had yo,
I was,
I couldn't see straight.
You know,
it's like,
um,
are you,
are you one of those guys that doesn't do well unless he gets eight hours?
Well I'm better now because having kids will break you from whatever habits you
think you have as far as sleep.
You will be broken like where you think you need eight hours.
You know,
like now the kids,
kids are older so they sleep like teenagers.
So,
but when the,
when they were younger that that,
that first year,
year and a half,
two years,
Yo,
it's,
it's like a shock to the system for real.
And especially if you have a kid that's not a big like a sleep,
especially if you're in this business too.
We have,
you know,
you,
you have,
you know what's weird,
like the amount of free time we have,
but so much of that is like panic of when am I going to get the next thing.
So it's not an enjoyable,
no,
it's not enjoyable at all.
They put the you do nothing.
I go,
I'm fucking walking around worried like you see me out and you think I'm doing
nothing.
All I'm doing is like trying to find like make sure I'm near a bathroom so I
don't,
you know,
like shit myself and like waiting for the phone ring.
I know that's what some guy said that a long time ago.
Send anybody in.
This business is a professional job hunter.
It's just like you're never,
you never,
you never can be like,
you can never rest easy.
I don't think I've ever met anybody that said,
you know what,
I've made it Leonardo.
He,
he,
he's good.
When you'd say it's money,
it's all money.
Never got married.
He never,
he's the pain in terms of like,
you know,
man Shit,
never got married,
does his shit.
He's the Jeter.
He's the GM of,
of of actors period.
And,
and also you'd be hard pressed to find anybody that has anything bad to say
about them.
Like when Derek Jeter.
Yeah.
Well you know,
like when you go with set,
you work with like,
and he's working on big movies like,
you know,
20,
30 movies,
however men and movie.
So it's like hundreds of people that he's come across.
And then there's fans and then there's the hundreds of women.
You don't hear anybody going that cock sucker this or he worked with me on this,
did just now he,
he's cool now,
but he knows how to,
he knows how to handle,
I met him one time,
right.
He's chill.
This is the funniest shit ever.
You know,
he's standing there.
Of course everyone wants to talk to him,
and the guy was,
what's it goes,
hey,
you want to meet the guy?
He's like,
I don't want to bug him like it's not going in and meet him.
So I fucking go over there.
And he goes,
Hey Leo,
this is a,
this is bill [inaudible].
He's a standup comedian.
And they just,
he just nodded.
He goes,
he goes,
what did he say?
He goes,
ah.
I'm familiar with this work.
Or he goes,
all right,
I've seen his work and just nodded like that.
It was perfect.
He knows saying no,
he didn't say it was good.
He didn't say it was bad and I could totally tell by the way he said that was
just,
I don't need another freckle jackass trying to say hello to me.
And I just went like,
oh,
hey,
Matt.
And I just walked away and I was just like,
he handled that perfectly perfect.
Okay.
Can you imagine?
I've seen his work,
that's it.
And he may or may not have seen the work.
You never know,
but,
but you walk away,
go.
You walk away feeling good about it.
The best rap it upskills that was on a whole other level because I walked away,
I felt good.
I met the guy,
right.
We had zero conversation of that just sort of way.
But it's a memorable thing.
Yes.
That's some,
that's some high level shits,
ninth degree black belt public figure read.
That's like some presidential like you know like running countries,
shit like sweats.
That martial art where they use,
she know a Kito where they'll use your energy and next thing you know like you
went to kick him and then the the four she used to kick the person.
You go flying into the wall.
That's what he did that did the make use it all against you.
I'm familiar with this work is not it gracious with eye contact.
The Blue Eyes would dig.
He gave me a quick eye contact.
You still don't know.
You're still trying to,
I don't remember.
I imagine that on a girl,
like you're just all fucked up in the game.
That sort of like elegance.
You don't know.
Like he liked les.
That's just like,
it's just soda.
Elegant.
So that I don't think that word has ever been used in this plug.
No.
Thank you for bringing that.
And especially the DiCaprio has that shit.
I mean in like,
you know,
you think about like,
you know the amount of people that he comes across on a daily basis.
Just think of like he's in New York.
Just think about Leonardo on a,
on a,
on a fall day in New York.
Like I picture his life grand central station,
five o'clock in the afternoon,
you're late for a train and everybody in there no shoe and wants to say hello
and you got to get from the door to and make the fucking train.
That has started to out.
He's not going to make it.
He could make it,
he can make it cause he's got it figured out.
He,
he would do and everyone would feel good and they would part and he would just
go right through.
What's the elegance?
Elegance of Leonardo Dicaprio?
That should be,
that should be his autobiography.
The unauthorized autobiography though.
But he couldn't,
he couldn't divulge your secrets and not everybody would know what the fuck he
was doing.
But what you said about the Aquillo's fucking totally right.
I came home and told my wife that I was,
it wasn't even like I was,
the excitement of meeting him was out shined by how he handled me.
It was fucking perfect.
That's like some Obama Shit.
Like that's presidential shit.
You know what I mean?
Cause people are like to like bugging,
you know I saw him and we blew me off and I was so fine with it.
It was awesome.
It was,
it was perfect.
It was fun.
It was a work of art.
You don't,
Leonardo is elegant.
I Dunno.
Maybe Game Tom Brady.
He's a good looking fella.
Tom.
No tights.
Who,
how do we get on fucking Leonardo Dicaprio?
I don't even know.
We were talking about job hundreds,
right?
Job Hunters.
Oh,
having it all figured out,
but you can't go back information ever making it.
Once you go backwards,
then that just becomes radio silence.
No.
The people who are going to be good,
they're hanging on the edge of the seat.
They want to see,
you know,
like I think a lot of them are laying down right now maybe driving.
What do you,
what do people do like with listening to majority of the podcast listeners of
the flight per airplane flights going to the gym,
going for a run in the car,
sit on the train.
A lot of commuters.
Yes.
So then be end up making them laugh and then people look at and like they're
fucking idiots.
I get a lot of,
I get a lot of tweets like that.
I was on the train laughing crazy.
Hysterical when you,
when you said this,
this and this or whatever.
Yeah.
That always makes,
I always makes me feel good.
How long have you been doing this?
June podcasting,
June or July of 2007 I'll say this again.
Bill Burr inspired me to do my own pop podcast cause the first time I went on
your podcast,
the first time when we make podcast history,
I had never been on a podcast and I was like,
what the fuck is you?
Did you have an inferiority complex?
No,
I didn't even know.
It was sort of just sort of,
it was just sort of brewing and and,
and,
and doing it.
So you're a man who has a lot of things to say,
man,
how the fuck did you get into the whole real housewives and then get onto,
it was the Andy Cohen show.
I'm with Andy Cohen show that is the Sports Center Sports Center for women.
Yes.
For and Ken and gay men and me,
and I have to say this,
it's one of the brilliance of that show brilliance.
I'll tell you what it is,
is how of Koan or the housewives in general of him doing the show because all he
has to do is just stir it up a little bit and then sit back and they're going to
fill out all,
he just goes.
He'll just be like,
so Mandy,
in episode two,
yes,
you were going through this,
this and this.
And then Karen said that the reason you can't get a man is because,
and then he just fucking sits back and they go out.
And it's the most brilliant show I've seen since when Byron Allen used to do,
uh,
comics unleashed.
Oh Huh.
And this is the brilliance he produced.
Not,
that's incredible.
Now he produced the show,
right?
It was,
he owned the fucking show and syndicated it.
Okay.
He doesn't have to have any writers because comedians would come in with their
own bits and then he knew what bits you were doing.
So all he had to do is just sit there and be like,
uhh.
So Michael,
ah,
have you ever been to a Knicks game?
And then you just go,
as a matter of fact,
I have,
and you just go full,
go into your bit.
And then he just sits back as you eat up that fucking time with your own fucking
comedy.
And then he would go over there.
So Judy,
uh,
you're counting the money in his hand and bloody fucking brilliant.
That guy is the king of finding the show where no one sees the shelf,
but they,
but it stays on the,
I remember them coming up next week coming up now he took press junkets.
Yup.
It was like this is a fucking show.
And he was like,
before Tmz,
he was doing that shit and it was going,
I'll bet you Byron Allen,
have you ever been interviewed him?
No.
I've met him a few times,
but that guy is a fucking genius and he has like three quarters Oprah money and
nobody even knows.
So I was just going to say that mother fucker's price so fucking we made it.
Absolutely made it.
He's probably like you,
you like,
you think I'm a fucking joke and yeah,
that motherfucker was doing that.
Owning and ownership.
Any indication he came in on,
uh,
on,
that's incredible.
That's incredible.
He was not even the star.
He was like the fuels 19.
Yeah,
like the fourth banana.
He,
he,
he was a kid.
He was like straight out the fucking business.
Yes.
Yeah.
I like all of those.
Yeah,
I think he's good.
Um,
oh,
so the was he's not getting 1 cent residual check.
Nah,
he ain't getting them shit.
I just got one the other day for 47 cents.
We have this,
this game,
uh,
you meet Al Madrigal sends it to me.
So it's almost like a game of poker where you just take a picture of your
residual check to going all the way down.
You,
you and Al Madrigal the two people I know that actually got literally got a 1
cent 1 cent residual from,
I don't even know what it was,
but I cashed the shit they used to.
They used to be.
I did.
Fuck that.
I was like,
I thought I did something that I now either liked or didn't like to get this one
sense and it's never coming in.
This is the bottom,
this residual,
this cycle.
However those things get get to you.
I never understand how they get to,
but this whole he said,
oh it gets to is is the money all goes to somebody else.
And then they had this algorithm on how it works off the first time they pay you
the second time it's half that and then it's you're just complete thousand feet
of water and then at one sense will come in and the partners allows and dollar
gig.
Then you get a residual for six 66 something like that.
And then three 32 no,
no,
no.
It goes six 66 down to like $3 and 32 so it wasn't that big of a jump.
I feel it does.
I don't know.
I eat cause that whatever,
that's not the point.
The point is about how's,
well this is how I got into housewives.
My girl,
Yeah Lady,
my lady,
she,
she would watch housewives on Sundays and a few seasons ago,
I don't remember what happened.
A few seasons go Sunday during football season,
something went bad for me.
So normally I'd be downstairs watching the late game,
the,
the Sunday night football game.
And by the time I got up there,
the,
the housewives shit would be over.
So what something happened where something happened with my team or the game,
it's something was bad and a mother fuck this game.
And I went upstairs early and I,
and I was like,
you know,
she's like,
what the fuck are you doing up here?
I was like,
oh,
she's well don't come up here with your bullshit.
I don't want to watch a fucking game.
I'll watch this shit with you.
And I swear to God,
Bill,
I don't know if you watch housewives or not,
but I was like first of all,
as an actor,
and I'm not like,
oh it's an actor,
I'm a people watcher.
But I was like so fascinated by the behavior.
I was like,
Yo you,
you every actor should be watching this.
Every actress should hundred and 50% be watching because it's mainly women.
But I was just fascinated that these people are for real.
They have cameras on them and you know,
people think it's fake.
You.
Marlon Brando on his best day.
Meryl Streep on his best day,
couldn't do some of the shit that I see on these housewives show.
So I just fell in love with,
I was just like,
Yo,
this is fucking nuts.
And I was like,
who's this one?
She was telling me all the stories and I was like,
this is fucking crazy and no bullshit.
I will put the shit up against it.
What is the name of the show?
You just submit the Aaron Paul show bojack horseman.
Bojack horseman,
which sounds dope.
Fucking breaking bad.
Bill burr was on breaking bad,
Blah Blah.
I swear on my,
on my kid's feet,
that a great episode of real housewives.
I will put it up there with the best of the Sopranos.
I'm not saying it's better,
but as far as the entertainment value of a great episodes of real housewives to
same fucking thing.
Nobody and you're looking at me like,
no,
I understand if you're looking at it as far as like ideas for characters just
entertained,
pure entertainment,
pure entertainment.
I saw a long time ago on on one of those bounty hunter shows,
right?
This guy did the greatest delivery of this,
of the,
of a line where he,
he,
his wife came running up to him.
Excuse accusing of him of something.
So he started off going like I wasn't,
and then he got mad and said I wasn't again.
And then he was like,
then he immediately hit,
did the math in his head like,
don't get mad.
So he wouldn't like that.
She came out like,
what the fuck are you blah blah.
And he goes,
he goes,
I wasn't,
I wasn't he,
he did every fucking thing you can't.
And I was just,
and I remember watching that,
I did say to Nia,
I was like,
dude,
if any actor ever did that with the academy awards on a,
on a page,
what you're,
you're working for another 20 years.
That's it.
You're,
you're great.
So,
so it's not like I sit there and watch it as it,
as an actor sound like I'm studying it,
but that's what I was like,
Yo,
this is fucking wild.
Like,
Yo this.
And I was like asking her questions and I was like,
this is how they act.
This is for real.
She goes,
yeah,
this is fruit.
This one's that one.
It was like,
they're dead series arguing like they're crying.
I was like,
people can't do that.
Fucking Meryl Streep can't cry like a lunatic whenever she wants aren't.
She was on her best day.
She couldn't do that check,
so I just,
I fell in love with it and believe me,
I sit there and watch it.
Shame with shame,
but I also know that this is as good as TV on any channel.
I'm telling you,
I put,
I am telling you in terms of what you get in terms of like when you watch a
great episode of whatever show you're into it,
it doesn't matter.
Whenever show people have an affection for,
it can be CSI la.
When you turn off the channel,
when you turn the show off,
when it ends,
literally you're looking at me like I'm nuts.
You're when,
when,
when a good episode of real housewives ends,
we clap at the fucking TV.
I'm like,
I'm in a fucking Broadway show.
You lost me there.
I,
I'm with you with the character stuff and the crying and all that shit.
But like,
you know,
if you can just fucking sit there and act like,
I'm telling you then an episode of the Sopranos,
I'm not saying it's better,
I'm saying it gives you entertainment,
entertainment,
value fan on.
I get depressed when I watch it and I come home and I feel like I fucking live
with them after a while and then never in a good mood.
And all they do is scream and yell at each other.
And I have no problem with this.
My mind is much screaming and yelling at each other here.
Yeah,
but it's,
but w we're having fun though.
That's true.
And I'm not saying hurtful shit.
Right.
I'm not saying like this really hurtful shit to you that I,
that I mean,
right,
right.
You know,
and then we have like this big fucking falling out and like,
and I'd walk off the set and then like,
you know,
someone subs who do really good new,
I'm not going to record anymore with bill.
He said about me.
No,
I'm just saying,
but like what kills me was my wife is a feminist.
Does she love it?
Yes.
And it just like,
I go like this shows women in such a bad light that all they want to do is go
around and get these fucking stupid ass shoes and I just scream and yell at each
other.
But she goes,
look,
I just watch it.
Cause sometimes I don't feel like thinking because she also,
we'll watch some other shit.
But she mainly watches that stuff.
And she's not telling you the truth about the thinking.
She's engaged.
She's,
she's thinking what she's watching.
I can't read your wife's mind,
but I want tell you the,
I know it.
I've had conversations with the wife about it.
I've had conversations,
we've discussed it.
She loves it.
Like I,
you know,
I hit,
it makes me sad is,
is watching these women in their forties and 50s trying to dress.
That's crazy.
Two,
it's like you look at it,
they're exhausted.
Yes,
yes.
Like you're an ebony used the word gear and your elegant years.
Yes,
I agree.
Like there's a guy,
I'm in my sport coat years.
I agree.
I hear no more tank tops.
For me.
I hear some cleaning out the garage and I know no one in the general public is
going to see my fucking flabby ghost white arm.
I hear you.
But like watching them that it'll wire and forever 21 I don't like that shit
cause so many of them.
They really like the attractive I what the Botox who fucking done up?
It's like the Oscars on a Tuesday for coffee.
Oh yeah,
it's insane.
And then the one with the little fucking plugged nose she's out of which one are
you drunk?
I don't even know what you don't even know what show are you even talking like
you don't even know what this one,
there's one where the pug nose on every show.
No,
it's like a,
it looks literally,
it looks like,
you know back when you had a train set and there was a tunnel and the tunnel
out.
That's what a nose looks like.
A goal.
I'm upside down you and the whole thing,
they can see both sides.
Yeah.
And she won't name names cause we would all like,
you know,
but then you,
you fucking watch it and like this screaming and yelling at each other.
I get it.
The only time I'll I'll get into it is the Jersey one I liked because the guys
are funny.
Yeah,
they're good.
The core gun,
I falsified some loans watching them.
Gee I guess I need to look at the papers more like that type of sociopathic
behavior where it's like,
it's like,
dude,
you're,
you're busted out in the open.
They all know that you did it.
Yes but,
but the physical rounds sign in Shit and you don't know what it is you're
talking about real housewives of New Jersey.
But the thing for me when I keep watching,
they went to jail and then the reality like you see like this family,
like I'm saying as far as,
I hate to say entertainment,
but that's what it is.
Like you follow the story like it's fucking Dallas or knots landing.
Once,
once that kids would cry and that the dad was going,
I couldn't watch it anymore because it was too painful.
I don't want to see that shit cause it,
it hit the heart.
Right.
But you see what I'm saying?
If you're watching it.
But there's also that other element of like,
why the fuck are you airing this?
Why didn't you just,
I hear you have to show,
why would you put your kids on TV?
I don't have the choice.
I get it.
But,
but I am all in straight up.
Do you watch the Kardashians?
My not,
not as,
not as religious as my girl watches it.
So we,
I watch it but it's not like I have to watch it.
That was the worst.
That's a fucking cause they don't have any problems.
No.
And they just keep going.
Problem is,
as I left my fucking $30,000 bag and the other generally $30,000 back,
how am I going to get that over here?
And now they throw the brother on there and the brother who I've met,
I've come across him and like,
you know,
like celebrities should in basketball game here for your famous guy,
man.
Yeah.
So I know Rob Kardashian,
you know like I know people like that.
Rob Kardashian,
I'd never,
you had all the big Hollywood party but he's on his show now and I'm,
I'm thinking like,
Yo,
he's,
he's a fragile dude.
Like that dude does not look like he should be on a reality,
a reality show.
And they're like,
just keep going and you,
Yo,
you're like,
this dude's shouldn't be on a reality and look what they did to poor fucking
Lamar Odom.
They fucking put him down into the ground.
Who did fucking,
she was,
he was,
he was married to,
what's the name?
And like every guy that they come across,
if they don't fuck with it,
it's like they get a curse on them.
The other one,
Scott Disick,
you watch your shows?
No,
you don't want them at all.
This neo watching.
Why am I doing a pocket?
I should be doing this.
This is funny to me.
This is getting it out here to fuck.
I want to find something.
It's like after football sports it's like I want to have somebody to talk to,
but I like the shows.
But my,
the housewives or my shit.
And it's fascinating.
I know,
trust me,
Bill,
I'm not a lot of actors also like they feel guilty when they watch them cause
they feel like,
oh,
these should be scripted shows and,
and I'm,
I'm contributing to this.
But I don't think that's a problem at this point.
There's enough fucking scripted shows for everybody to have a job.
I agree.
I,
you know,
at first I resent the reality shows,
but now I think,
you know,
they're,
they're finding,
I think,
well,
let,
let's,
let's get it back on track.
The Patriots are playing the buffalo bills next week.
Now,
Julian Edelman,
uh,
this,
they can't that,
you know,
uh,
Garappolo might come back.
Yeah,
he might be back.
Did you see what the Patriots and other teams are doing it too?
But of course they just bring up the Patriots.
It's not cheating,
but it's fucking brilliant.
Well,
what are they doing?
Why did you preface it by saying it's not cheating?
I didn't say it was because they present it like it was.
Okay.
What was it?
So this,
this new rule that when you,
when you kick the ball out,
you kicked the ball and the ends off the guy catches the ball.
If he takes a knee rather than going to the 20 all these years,
now it goes to the 25 so they gave him that extra five yards because they're
trying to avoid the collisions.
Yes.
So you just giving them the fucking 25 yard line,
which is a fucking it that is a,
that is a fucking like what would you say are on,
are on a grade like a B plus return?
A minus year I get a return is 25 yard line.
If you kick in the end zone and you add the guide downs,
it,
it's the 25 yard line.
I didn't fucking know.
It's a new rule.
That's a new rule this season.
Yup.
So this is the thing,
if you take a fucking personal,
cause I that's what I was saying,
cause this guy,
I finally looked it up because I saw somebody take a personal foul on the other
team and it's like that's a 15 yard penalty.
First down.
I'm like,
all right,
there on the 35 and they went on the 40 and I was like,
aw,
here's,
it's so what the Patriots are doing.
It's like uncertain situations that they,
they,
they just booted up in the air.
So it lands on like the half yard line,
the three yard line,
or just into the end zone to entice these people to run it out.
Right.
So they can stop them before the 25 and we got to fumbles doing that against the
Texas.
Right.
And it's just one of those fucking things where it's just like Bella check was
like,
okay,
that's the fucking rule.
Where can we get our advantage?
And it's one of those smart dog.
Exactly.
And that's half of the Shit,
you know,
I talk to people,
Hey,
he's the motherfucker,
man.
He is.
And you know,
I'll be honest with you,
I,
you know,
like,
cause you think that I,
I don't want to see them do good.
No bullshit.
I would love just to see just for the,
at the accomplishment of it,
if,
if Edelman doesn't mean,
if that'll make does play,
let's say,
uh,
um,
preset that preset and Garappolo can't play and fucking Julian Addleman plays
quarterback and they somehow when an NFL football game,
they should just stop playing the game like this season because to me that will,
let's not get crazy.
I mean we,
we haven't played like the greatest teams.
It doesn't matter if you could win a football game with Julian Edelman is your
starting quarterback.
I don't give a fuck who you're playing for real.
And that's,
that's,
that's an exaggeration with one week preparation that Julian Edelman to be,
I mean he's not even that,
that would be crazy first of all,
but it wouldn't you and playing buffalo.
Right.
Would you agree though?
Yeah.
That's going to be at the toughest game because in Buffalo,
because Rex Ryan is a,
he's a great coach and he's smart.
Two aunts of mine and he,
and he has a heart on force and his lifetime record against Bella check is,
I think it's maybe a couple games under 500 seats.
It personal jet.
Yeah.
Every year we fucking went,
it was like we won and they won.
They won one and now he's got his brother there and they're,
you know,
they're smoking fucking weed because the brother,
it's rex.
And what's Ryan when mean,
what's the other rex?
Ryan and the,
what's the brother's name?
The one who looks like fucking the dude runs a tilt a world,
that fucking guy.
Right?
I mean those guys are gotta be no that great.
They're great.
So I mean,
I was not happy when rex got fired.
I don't like seeing people get fired,
but like I knew he was going to catch on somewhere else,
but when he was still in our division,
I'm like,
fuck,
I still
got to see this guy twice a year.
But he makes it fun though.
He makes it like,
to me like that guy and like,
he definitely makes it fun.
But my thing is,
I don't like a guy who talks shit when he has a good team and then clams up when
he has a bad team.
It's like still talking shit.
Like that's the whole thing.
And like he's,
he's not,
not,
not the way when we want to put the jar,
he dialed it back.
But he swayed back.
He,
but he's still like,
I saw this whole thing on him,
the way he talks to his team and all like the,
you know,
ray Lewis and all them were like,
what the fuck is he like,
we don't need that pep talk.
Like he's talking,
I'm like,
it's a high school team.
You know,
he's still like,
we got to get out there and kick their fucking answers.
It's the Buffalo Lewis.
Ray Lewis never needed a pep talk.
A professional summer.
Somebody else probably does great rate for game three and the in the NFL season.
No,
I love Ray Lewis.
One time they did.
I was think I told the story.
One of those outside the lines with Bob Lee or something,
uh,
on ESPN and he was in,
they had this intense music and he was fucking talking about how,
you know,
his dad wasn't as in his life at that time.
So when he went to high school,
he just,
he just went on a fucking Taylor and his dad owned all the records and he broke
all the fucking records,
all the football games or something.
Every time I looked up in the stands and he wasn't up there and made me go even
harder.
Dude,
this dude was so fucking inspirational.
I went to the gym like every day for like three weeks after that because every
time I didn't want to go,
I just kept thinking,
well right Ray Lewis would go right,
right.
Lewis is going to the same thing from watching a Coby doc fiduciary,
Coby dark now dude,
you know I,
I'm a Celtics fan.
I can't watch anything pro Lakers yo that now I could watch it cause he's out of
the fucking loose.
You watch it if you want like that.
Kinda like,
I want to work out like psycho,
like he's a fucking like now he's a maniac and he's what?
She fucking pass the ball more.
Yeah,
I never,
that was my big fucking like,
I actually think that they would have won a couple more if he did.
Absolutely.
I think that if he had it together,
I think if he had,
I can say that to have him.
I've never played the game on any sort of,
to me,
I'm going to say he would have won two more.
I want to tell you what years.
Right.
And I won't even tell you why.
I'm just going to say that.
You're just going to go out on the record and say,
but,
but you want some water?
No,
I'm good.
You're just going to chop ice the microphones you to finish what you were saying
about the patriots cause I want to hear what you,
you,
your,
your first of all that you know about.
Okay.
When I was going to play,
what I was going to say is I know what,
look,
I've watched enough football to know that when in three,
four games in September is not even,
doesn't even 10% equal up to winning game one of the playoffs in January.
Of course.
Okay.
Cause you're going to run,
it's better than losing three games in the second number,
but you're going to run to a fucking teams that are rebuilding.
You're going to run and run with teams that have bad ownership,
that have a bad coach.
Some people that have lost the fucking locker room,
like you'll get your injury,
those games,
you're going to get those games like anybody can fucking it these days with all
these fucking rules can throw 304,
300 yards.
Yes.
Between September,
yes,
and I would say mid November,
but then when it really starts tightening up and Oh,
it also depends on when you play comes January.
Okay.
When it's one and done,
if you fucking lose like all of a sudden like you know you're not
now ethnic each week it gets harder and harder and harder.
Yes.
The ownership,
the coaches,
the players,
everything gets better and better and better tighten up.
Tighten up.
Exactly.
It's like one of those fucking muscle bound guys.
They start drinking water but and just,
there's no,
no fat,
no fat.
What they did to fucking the Texans.
The Texans have one of the best defenses in the,
it was a joke.
I mean they kicked her ass.
Well that's,
that comes down to like,
you got to understand what you're dealing with with the Patriots is you have a
top three owner all time.
I already think,
Nah,
maybe that's not to be disrespectful to like,
cause dude,
you got to go George Hallis.
There's a lot of great,
but you have to be you.
I love that.
You just don't give a fuck.
Are you going to chomp that ice right into the microphone?
People know.
People know,
no,
don't care.
Can I want to use that next time?
Mia gives me shit for doing something within my math.
People know they don't care.
Like dude,
his fucking,
his three coaching hires have been bill Parcells,
Pete Carroll,
Bill Bellacheck,
right.
There's two quarterbacks have been drew Bledsoe.
Tom Brady.
Is that it?
That's it.
Damn.
That's fucking good luck to men.
It that is good luck with the fact that Brady's able to play this long is good
luck.
Oh,
somebody told me they know a guy that knows a guy that knows him and it's like,
that guy literally knows what he's having for lunch like three years.
I'm sure he's probably,
he's like a closet Kolbe.
He's a fucking lunatic.
You have to be,
you had also its lunches.
It's funny to me the injuries are luck,
Pronoun and injuries.
And you know what Slaac is that he got to play for bill.
Bill Bellacheck absolutely the same way per show.
Montel Montana was lucky that he got to play for Fucking,
uh,
Bill Walsh.
Yeah.
I would say Dan Marino was unlucky to play with Don Shula when he was towards
the end of his career.
I agree.
Because the,
the game had changed and when Bill Walsh came in with the west coast offense and
all that,
and that fucking guy for as much shit as he gets,
look up his running backs right.
That he had,
that guy never had a running game,
never had a fucking running game.
He never really had is uh,
Jerry.
He had duper and Clayton that more.
Right.
He never had like a Randy Moss,
right level fucking guy and like,
you know,
his defense was the killer bees.
They had like the last two like white quarterbacks ever.
Ever.
Yeah.
It was like the Blackledge ledger,
blackwood brothers while and Kyle's yes,
I remember that.
Yeah.
That was Jay Dewey.
Bob.
Yes.
Students.
It looked like the 72 team,
the amount of fucking white dudes that were on that thing.
Yeah.
Um,
no disrespect to any of those guys,
but what the fuck?
No,
it's shit,
it's shit that that guy was going.
Absolutely.
It was like,
was he supposed to tackle people too,
right?
I mean that guy,
like the amount of rule changes that they had to make in the NFL for his fucking
like 84 season record phrase ball.
And he did that back when I think you could spy 84,
you could still wear stick them.
I know that it was like covering receivers.
What's my man's name on it?
Oh Mom.
Oh Hey.
Yes,
the fucking Hayes.
And I think it was eerie is Lester Hayes.
Aren't you getting him on the podcast?
Lester Hayes.
Cause I figured he's busy
doing something.
One of the great suck to something.
Yeah but I think you know and that was still like the Mel blunt rules as far as
coverage and all of that.
What they've done is they say some of it's for safety.
I think most of it,
it means it's always about money.
Even if they say it's about safety,
it's not cause they give a fuck about the players is cause they don't want to
deal with another class action law suit.
Right.
And then also they know that offense offense sells like here's the deal dude.
You and I do.
Do you watch fucking soccer?
No.
Let's say each game was like 10 to eight.
You want to watch,
you have more appeal to watch because I don't understand that 90 minutes and
it's one zero get the fuck out in our last call might come in the last minute
thing though.
But if you,
if you go into a s uh,
football bar,
it's switch what they really call it.
Or if you're over in England and they're watching the premier league and people
are fucking end of this shit,
right.
I always say when I stand there,
it's like I wouldn't,
I just need to live in this country for about three weeks and I would have a
team and I would have a scarf and I would be learning the socks.
Right.
I know that that's true.
But the thing is is we already got,
we got our four,
it's cultural.
I see.
I still watched like I still watch a little bit of tennis,
right?
I'll watch the golf.
I got into Formula One racing.
Like I kind of all over the place,
man.
I go watch that shit for me.
One racing.
Yeah,
I love it.
And you're talking to me about housewives.
You weren't fucking cars.
Go Zoom,
zoom.
Well it's not like Nascar where they just drive around in a giant circle.
There's like left and right turns this all kinds of shit.
And then you know what else love.
It's Sorta like the Illuminati sport,
you know what I mean?
Like yachting is fucking,
it's like you have to know how to sail to see what the fuck's going on there.
Right.
That shit is just like,
like I remember the right,
the first race that I watched this year.
I kind of watch it every year as the one in Monaco.
I know nothing.
You're like eight and I'm like,
I'm supposed to be like,
yeah,
okay.
I don't know.
Right.
The France,
you know Monica?
I actually never been to France,
believe it or never been.
A friend won't let me in Paris.
The mother never went to Cannes or anything.
I never went to cons.
Never been to Paris.
It's I need to go.
You got to go.
I know.
I know you.
When I say right now,
you bring your fucking wife,
they're over over and you know what's great to can throw it in their fucking
face for a while.
Right?
You can do.
That'll work for you for about a year,
year and a half now.
It's a woman too.
It's about six weeks.
Okay.
It's a great six week.
Paris,
France.
The whole thing.
He touched you.
You just take into Paris and it just,
this is what I do.
Like I,
I don't look at her when I say it,
I just sort of stare out the window and just talk to myself like,
Hey,
you'd think if Davy brought somebody to Paris,
right.
Keep it good for at least three days.
Cool.
And what goes cool from,
she always laughs,
he goes,
you don't take me to Paris to throw it in my face.
Go.
Yeah,
yeah,
I do.
Yeah.
I don't know 100% do that.
But like if you think that you're going to go to Paris and then come back here
and fucking call me on my shit,
you're not gonna hear about it.
I shouldn't be allowed to go off the rails.
Yeah.
I should be able to have a nice drink and habit.
Text her a picture of weeks.
She said,
what are you doing?
Are you texted her a picture of like you and her kissing under the Eiffel Tower?
I remember this.
You want to fucking break my balls though?
You don't want to.
I got this picture,
I get it.
I got it in my phone of Rihanna and she's courtside at a basketball game and
she's like looking up at the
scoreboard.
I don't know if she needs glasses but you know when people need glasses then
making that thing,
it's perfect the way she's looking.
So whenever Nia texts me something and I don't want to do it,
I just send her that picture and it looks like Rihanna is like looking up at it
like what the fuck is,
that always makes her laugh and I swear to God like 40% of the time I get out of
whatever the hell she wants me to do.
Do you do you find,
because I know I do like arguing as I used to be arguing of football,
you know,
no more don't seem so easy going.
I know.
Shocker,
right,
but in relationships I don't argue no more like I'm done.
I don't,
what am I cause not arm wrestling when I figured out there's no actual winning
and no actual losing.
Yeah,
there is no,
there isn't.
There isn't.
There is certain things on certain things.
There's certain certain behaviors,
certain behavior,
yes,
but 99% of the argument you have in a relationship with a woman or a man,
whoever's listening to this,
you have a big,
a lot of women listening to the show.
I don't think so.
Probably not.
Why?
Why would they,
why would they fucking wasted?
Because their husbands or boyfriends listened to and the public and I fucking
hate this guy.
I can't fucking stand these two of them and doing this shit.
Now it's usually one is usually the one guy's in there talking to himself as a
sausage fest,
Mike.
But,
but I don't,
I don't argue.
I mean,
Eh,
I'm not saying it's perfect,
but I,
the arguing that the bantering,
the bickering about little shit,
I don't do it.
That's the one thing that I've gotten being a little older and more experienced
divorce.
Oh,
I don't,
I don't bicker.
I don't pick up.
But if there's some bullshit,
right.
All right.
I'll own up to it.
Maybe not right then,
but I,
I couldn't,
I can within an hour cool off.
It'd be like,
you know,
right.
You put the hour so you need the hour.
I used to need forever because you called me one time.
Something was going,
I was like,
you would like we were,
you were,
we were arguing about Pa.
You were like,
am a job in the house and I'm an undetermined to fuck you and your fucking and
Cavaliers and they're going.
I was like,
what the fuck?
And then you were like going on,
I,
we're already,
you're like,
oh,
I'm walking.
I was up at my house and I was like,
what the fuck is wrong with this guy?
And I was like,
oh somebody,
another guy who's been married forever told me,
he goes,
just go for a walk.
So I started doing that,
but then what's fucked up is then I walked down the street with like Tourette's
and everybody's looking at me like I'm out of my mind talking to yourself,
talk on the phone,
talking to,
are you arguing with yourself based voice by yourself,
by myself.
Fuck and do it.
It's just every other word is fuck you want to hit something fucking hilarious.
So I'm doing the road this week and yeah,
we're at,
uh,
I'm doing a couple nights in Madison,
Wisconsin than a bone in Nebraska during the day I'm going to the corn husker
game.
Oh Shit.
Playing the lion,
I,
and then I'm going up to Omaha to do the show.
So I,
uh,
I go on one of these tickets sites to fucking get my tickets.
Right.
So I fucking,
you know,
pay through the nose to get them,
cause I,
I almost fight yourself.
You're going to the gun and I'm going with,
with the other Nate cry.
Right,
right.
Okay.
So I get these fucking tick,
you know,
I get the tickets,
I'm all set right now.
I'm thinking like it's a couple of days before the fuck one of these things
coming.
So I look on my confirmation thing,
it says we're going to overnight him.
It's like the day after I'm leaving,
so I fucking call up the one eight,
eight 88 number and blah,
blah,
blah.
I can't get anyone on the phone,
Yada,
Yada.
So I just say,
fuck this,
I'm going to these other guys.
Right.
And I fire off this email to the first people just go on like,
yeah,
this is my situation.
Blahblahblahblahblah why can't I talk to a person?
Why is it so difficult?
Why did your machine hang up on me?
And I said,
I'm going to fucking,
I go,
I have a podcast,
I'm going to trash you guys.
Right?
I forgot,
I forgot that my email.
Like just my name shows up,
right?
So I fucking,
I send this thing in this anger,
right?
And then I immediately go to this next slide.
Don't even wait for these people because they said,
if you have a problem sending right,
you don't even don't even wait for him to try to resolve it.
Right.
So I immediately go to the next one,
give me the two best you've got.
And I got a person and she was great.
I could talk on the phone.
It was all fine.
They gave it to me,
I print them out,
I'm all fucking set.
Right?
Fucking like three hours later I get this phone call.
It's like,
had a guy on the website,
he's like,
yeah man,
sorry.
You have a difficult time.
Well we'll have these things overnighted out to you.
I hope there wasn't any inconvenience.
No big deal.
A big fan of the podcast.
And I just,
I felt like an idiot.
I go,
all right man,
thanks a lot.
And now you've got four tickets for tickets that tonight I paid through the
nose.
That's fucking did you,
you didn't,
you just took it and were like,
okay,
thank you.
And you didn't,
you didn't,
you just kept it moving.
No,
cause I was rough.
I'm not addicted.
I am an idiot.
Right.
But I'm not a dick.
Like I was wrong.
And I was sitting there when they called back and there was something in my head
going like,
dude,
you should probably wait a couple hours.
But I was like in a panic because I hear you.
You thought it was going to the airport today.
I'm not going to the mall because I never look at my itinerary until like the
night before.
And uh,
yeah.
So,
you know,
my,
I'm,
I'm literally,
you know,
I'm to do,
I'm going to,
I'm going to put on a post it on my dashboard because the cars,
the big thing where I really feel bad for my wife,
right?
I'm just going to write like a,
I forgot I hadn't,
this little fucking thing I was going to write and all I know is it just ended
with God bless these cuts.
I was just going to put me in a silly mood and I'm like,
dude,
I almost need to like meditate before I go.
I hear you.
We mean you should go to meditation class.
I needed to know,
but I don't think you and I can't help each other.
Like I've had to,
right.
I one time,
you'll a third party need to intervene because a long time ago I remember,
I,
uh,
I w I dated this woman and she was an angry psycho into conspiracy theory too,
right?
And we were not a yin and a Yang.
Now you care and how,
you know,
and it's just like we just fed off each other and it was just this downward
spiral of negativity.
Anger stole that event at the world that eventually turned inward.
I got that was just like,
I agree.
Yes,
relationships.
You,
you,
you can't,
you can't like,
oh,
we're just the same bad.
All you young motherfuckers out there,
I'm not,
listen,
I'm not.
I'm a,
I'm a onetime loser.
I got divorced.
I have fucking bad history released.
I'm in a great one now.
But all that shit,
we're just the same.
No,
you don't have to send a red flag.
We know what the
sad,
you want to find somebody like we're just the same.
Do not do that.
That's a tip.
This is a sad thing out there.
This is really depressing for guys like you and me have to be with the
sweetheart.
Gado all right,
so with the sad thing is,
is so many sweethearts end up with people like us.
Like,
I always wondered like,
you know,
if it was a fair world,
I would end up with the version of me and then I would fucking,
we,
I would have to somehow try to bear myself natural love each other into fucking
like a day.
And I was like,
yeah,
and we wouldn't reproduce it.
And that would be fucking it.
But like sweet,
like,
I'm trying to think if I ever saw a couple where it was just two sweethearts.
Yeah,
I see that every once in a while.
You can't too.
Sweethearts will work too.
Sweet.
I sweetheart in a lunatic or work to lunatics.
It's,
it'll,
it'll get a bit of catch up with you.
You'll,
you'll eat each other from the inside 48 it's gone down.
Yeah,
absolutely.
It will catch up with you.
What?
You'll either kill each other,
your key or just emotionally dis rip yourself out.
Your innards,
who will be,
will be ripped out.
Hey,
before we got a little over an hour here,
I usually just do a half hour unless I get a great guest like you.
So let's wrap it up here.
Talking about the giants.
Yes,
no,
I'm going to talk about your giants here.
Go ahead.
Eli had one of his classic,
a September Games where he threw two picks and blah,
blah blah.
And then I know every mouth on the only the mouth breathing giant fans are like,
dude,
we gotta fucking get rid of this guy and blah,
blah,
blah.
My theory on Eli Eli is fucking board in September and October.
He's coasting and he has to wait till it's like,
Hey Eli,
we have to win the last six fucking games or else we don't make the playoffs.
And then,
and then he goes,
oh,
all right.
And you think because he wears a blue sport coat and fucking those Pete Carroll
Docker's no,
you just thinking that this guy doesn't have the Septum and that guy does.
He has it in him.
He's a motherfucker.
He gets the later it gets,
the better he is.
Yes he is.
And this is the thing,
dude,
like he doesn't have Payton's stats.
No,
but his fucking record in January into February,
I mean this is fucking insane.
He's got two rings.
They're playing Minnesota this weekend.
I'm scared of that Minnesota defense.
They did.
I heard they're good.
Yo.
They had Aaron Rodgers like they're the,
the the,
the offensive line was giving him protection.
The secondary they lock shut down.
Cam Newton,
they have guys on that team,
they're red blooded American straight goons.
They were body slam and Cam Newton not just sacking him.
Some mother fucker picked him up and threw him on the ground.
I was like,
what the f Cam Newton and they didn't throw a flag either.
Yo,
I think the ref was just like,
oh,
like scared.
Like it was like a violent sack.
Like he picked him up and through Cam Newton to the girl,
you have to,
you know strong.
You have to be to do that.
I don't know who it was and I saw him one time in real life too.
Like Kiss Cam,
Cam Newton.
He was the most amazing thing about that guy.
His feet dude.
His feet like he has like a size,
like it looked like a 20 yeah,
he's a fucking beast.
I just thought if I was like,
if that gave a walk by and accidentally if stuff I was wearing timberlands,
I probably still break to Towson.
Yeah.
And if he was walking he'll about rag man,
he's gigantic.
He's like six,
six,
I think gotta be at least six,
five like a real six,
five and like a fucking like,
like he's like a bodyguard like aside from being that good looking and handsome
you'd like this guy could be like outside of club,
like holding the whole shit down like a fucking good,
like he's goon size,
you know what I'm saying?
Like you know his head is like you should be in the VIP in his body as he should
be guarding the door.
He's a goon man and that fucking guy on the vikings,
I don't know who is not,
I didn't see that game but that immediately I was waiting for people to go like,
well how come if it's a white quarterback like Tom Brady,
all of a sudden the flags coming up.
And then I'm also thinking,
has he not been in the league long enough?
But I think he's making the league enough fucking money that from what people
said about that game,
he should have got a couple of Tom Brady.
Hey,
go easy on the dimple.
They gotta they gotta take it easy on them,
but this wasn't an illegal hit.
It was just like,
oh,
okay.
Well got him in his arms and literally like slammed him down.
He's like,
the guy didn't fall down on him.
Like he picked him up and threw him down.
Like he didn't like take him to the ground.
I still had the ball.
He had the fucking balls.
Okay,
well then forget he's a legal hit.
It wasn't like Denver where they were like,
you know,
going at his head,
it was just normal.
You see a guy like drew Brees get hit like that,
like a smaller guy like this guy to do that to Cam Newton.
I was like so divided.
What's funny too is drew breeze is huddles.
He's like six [inaudible],
right?
Six one probably what?
Two 2010 right.
But compared to Cam Newton,
he's like,
oh,
but wait,
but when,
yeah,
it was some saying like how tough those guys are that they could take a six one
210 pound guy who I just give my wallet too.
Right.
It could like throw him through the wall like nothing yet just bumping into him,
trying to get to the fucking running back zero.
Nothing don't though.
Those guys are,
but the vikings defense,
they're,
they're the most impressive thing that I've seen all season in terms of like,
I'm going to watch that game.
Who's,
who's your pick this year?
You've got to go with your heart.
Say that giants prepared.
I got to go you.
I'm like if you say who's going to win the Superbowl and I say the Patriots,
I'm not saying who I want.
Like if I say who do I think is going to win the Superbowl?
I say the Patriots are going to right now based on the injuries and the way
everything is now,
it's four weeks in,
you know like long ways off.
But if you add like I think Seattle's a wrap look good.
I hear the eagles look good quarterback,
but there he,
oh,
he's,
he's only three games.
He's not just all right.
He's superseded.
But you know,
you think,
I mean we need to what?
They haven't had a quarterback since fucking Donovan McNabb superseded the fact
that he wasn't even going to fucking suit up the first week.
And He,
I mean he,
he had,
he did he the 3.0 and he's a big part of it.
It's not like they're doing some trickery like Cleveland where like just making
it happen.
Or if like Edelman plays for a quarterback,
like he's a fucking quarterback.
Like he's there three and now like San Francisco and,
and,
and Philadelphia and the preseason,
you were like,
they're not going to score points.
Like,
you know,
they traded Stan Bradford and then this Guy Carson Wentz and all of a sudden
there's these,
I'm Sam Bradford in Minnesota.
He is,
and the,
and then the other quarterback was supposed to start before Carson Wentz.
And then whenever we're born your fence,
listen,
Bill Burr,
what do you got to promote?
What I got nothing.
I got the iron Rapaport Stereo podcast.
I want to officially say at some point when bill burrs,
in traveling,
selling,
selling out arenas,
we will eat this food,
this steak.
I will pay my debt.
I'm not avoiding that.
So don't fucking tweet me with your shit and your threats and all that bullshit,
but I appreciate you having me on.
It's always a pleasure.
I did.
I did go on record saying that.
If you ask me right now,
who would win the Super Bowl?
I said,
whoa.
You said the Patriots.
I didn't say I wanted it to happen,
but I said it can.
The Patriot,
I'm taking the pages right now based on all every,
everybody stays healthy.
What about your fucking guy real quick?
Gronk Koski when did he,
what's his problem?
What do you mean?
They're like,
oh he's,
he all of a sudden he's hurt.
He's not playing.
What's that bullshit about?
Well,
they always disguised.
They don't want to say where the guy's hurt.
They don't want the animals to go after it.
Okay.
It's all right.
Cause I know you're not in the fantasy football,
but you know even that even New England Patriot diehards that are in the fantasy
that drafted the Gronk and the first round they got fucked because they didn't
say anything about any injuries.
How did he get fucked?
Because you should leave like you didn't lose my league.
You know I can't,
but if you don't like fantasy,
you're so fucking stupid.
I love it.
It's the stupidest shit out of it.
You all this shit that I was just talking about eight drafted him.
I get a moment,
it's like
I'm a fucking gem.
Eminem.
I'm an owner.
I own a finish.
It's like playing risk.
I love it when people play risk and they start feeling like that they're Hitler
taken over Europe or some shit.
The reason why you're playing a board game,
I,
I totally have a different appreciate like I could talk about every teams when I
do like about fantasy football is you guys know the players way more than I do.
Then a normal fan,
I don't have time.
I know half of you guys could do color commentator who like the backup punter is
cause he's fucked you on.
Absolutely.
You guys who play fantasy football and degenerate gamblers.
No,
as much as a color commentator.
Absolutely.
I and I played in low stakes.
It just was fun.
But that the,
the biggest thing,
the biggest takeaway from all of the,
I mean the shit talk I like,
I love the shit talk,
but the thing that I really take away from it is that I have a whole different
appreciation for the entire league.
Not just the giants are not just the jets are just the Patriots,
the teams that are against the giant.
Well I will say back in the,
when I was a kid and I collected football cards,
I knew every stat,
I knew what college you went to,
academia,
offensive line type of shit of everybody.
And,
and what I hated was when I,
when I got a little older,
I was like,
you know,
I'm going to go back to doing that because it was a cool way to,
uh,
to learn it right down to go on a website.
And try to figure this shit out.
It's a pain in the ass.
Um,
you just had the guy,
you flipped it over.
They had every season and then they didn't do that anymore.
Right when I stopped cars and then they try to make certain you couldn't just
buy the set.
No.
And they're like an electronic cards and they tried to make them RF artificially
rare so they're worth something because you know,
I guess a bunch of guys my age,
he started collecting again for the wrong reasons.
I wanted to collect just cause I wanted to get to know them cause my first 10,
12 years of doing stand up,
like I just was working
so much,
I kind of lost touch with like a generation of players and I just wanted to go
meet too.
Yeah.
And I wanted to really go back into collecting cars and stuff just so I could
just have 'em out.
Like,
I'd,
you know,
I'd rather have them out on the table and just line them up the way they were
telling me when I would watch a game and the guy would make a play and I would
just turn over it like even like block,
my dad used to be like Jesus Christ,
you know,
every,
but meanwhile I was flunking everything and Beasley Reese was out too.
I R C Thielemann,
I knew all the guys on Falcons.
I knew all of these fucking guys.
Joe De Lamea,
I knew all of these offensive guards and,
and,
and I just fucking knew everybody.
I knew where they went to school,
all this fucking trivia.
I knew what the size cleat that Louie Culture War,
right?
Rare facts,
all of that.
She was mom's name.
His mom's name is lovely,
you know,
like some weird shit on the back of the car.
He wants returned three fucking scores for a touchdown when he played in high
school and like,
and then the commentator would say it,
my dad be like,
for Christ's sake,
how do you know that?
I'd be like getting attention from him.
I certainly wasn't with you were getting the wrong kind of attention with the
report card.
So I do,
that's the only thing about fantasy.
That's what I love about it.
That does appeal to me.
But sitting there,
uh,
I dunno it,
it just seems so fun.
Can time consuming.
It's not,
it's always,
it's time consuming as it is.
You make it like,
I mean I,
I'm fucking nuts with it because I'm like obsessed with it cause you're crazy
cause I'm crazy.
But,
but the,
the,
the re my rejuvenation for the NFL because when I had my kids Sunday would be
kids time.
So I lost track of a lot of shit for like either because you're fucking sleeping
because it's the weekend or you're like,
oh you gotta go to fucking drive them to their games.
Flag football games or football games or parties or fucking Bar Mitzvahs at this
pool party and sit there and talk to other parents while the fucking giants are
winning full.
Is that experience.
Oh my God,
you're going to,
you know,
if you,
and you have kids,
whoa my goodness.
It's going to fucking parties.
And socializing with people and no,
I'm not going to be a good thing.
It's tough.
It's rough,
but I'm bad at that.
Not being a parent,
it's,
it's going to,
boy,
you're going to have to do it.
When you have kids,
you have to do it because it's not like la where you're like,
go outside and play.
I'm just,
I'll draft behind you that day ever comes.
I'm telling you,
she'll it,
she'll go with a big smile and do you have a boy your,
there's no way to avoid it.
It,
it,
you have to do it.
And it's,
it was,
it was rough for me to do.
Like it's so outside of my thing,
I like to sit there and like,
when they're four and five at like Spiderman is at the party and Spiderman's in
a jumpsuit and his fucking balls are flopping around and you're talking to the
other parents,
he's like,
so what do you do it like,
ah,
you don't know who the fuck I am and no,
this is
the best in the ally.
Yeah.
Well I'm a,
I drive a truck.
Yeah.
Well,
I had computers.
I used to say I'm in computers,
but then they would ask me a followup question and I'll just went off the rails.
You don't have plan B?
Yeah.
What kind of computers?
The computers do lap laptops.
Yeah.
Sell them.
You work at apple store.
All right bill.
I'm out.
Wrapped us up.
All Right Mike,
we'll wrapping it up with Michael Rappaport.
Uh,
thanks for coming on.
Picking the Patriots fantasy football.
You can,
uh,
you can catch him on Andy Cohen show.
So a Zillion fucking movies and the Michael Rappaport.
I am Rapaport Stereo podcast Stereo Stereo.
I'm out.
Wow,
right.
He is the uh,
is he advertising here for Thursday?
You know,
what are you going to do?
This is obviously recorded later as you can tell them a tone of my voice.
Rapaport is left.
All right.
Lift everybody.
You know about Lyft,
right?
Do you,
it's the APP that gets you a ride in minutes on demand 24 motherfucking seven
for less than the cost of a cab.
Please include all the following points.
If you fucking write it.
I'm going to read this.
Give us the keys.
Um,
if you've tried Lyft,
you know what I mean?
With lifts,
you just download the APP,
request a driver,
and they show up in three and a half minutes.
On average.
That's really fast.
Every Lyft driver is fully vetted through that 10 point safety standard.
Unlike those other people that you can walk out of jail and just become up,
I can't say the name,
but it rhymes with scrubber.
Um,
including criminal and DMV background checks,
you know,
you'll get around quickly and safely.
That's right.
Lift is dotting all the i's and crossing all the t's.
Dude lifts are rated after every dried,
so only the best ones stick around.
You don't have to worry about getting to a filthy car with some creepy dude.
Meann.
With Lyft,
you can tip in the APP,
which is obviously leads to happier drivers.
Nine out of 10 Lyft rides get a perfect five star rating from the passenger.
It's just a better overall experience.
Bigger isn't always better.
Lift isn't the biggest ride sharing app,
but it's the fastest growing and highest rated one.
I'm talking about quality over quantity.
People,
you know,
it's like he got that roommate,
he's out there at bang and a bunch of threes,
right?
He's in the triple digits,
but you're,
you're,
you're banging sevens,
eights,
occasional nine and every once in a while you get a 10.
You know,
sky's hitting singles,
spraying them all over the field.
But you're,
you,
you're going fucking yard every once in a while,
right?
Yay.
And then into the triangle at Fenway park,
getting that triple you get,
you get double softer,
the fucking monster.
Um,
thanks to the lift,
you got an easy way to avoid drunk driving.
You never have to burn a ride and you never have to worry about parking.
A lot of people are actually getting rid of their cars and relying on Lyft to
get around.
You know what?
I don't blame them.
Evidently I do blame them.
You never want to go to the countryside.
You dumb.
Fuck right now.
Lyft is offering our listeners a special deal.
Get free rides up to $10 each.
That's a $30 value when you enter Promo Code Bill Burr.
Just download the free Lyft app today and enter the Promo Code Bill Burr and the
payment is section a payment.
A section sounded Italian that you start with free three free rides up to $10
each.
That's up to a $30 value.
That Promo Code is bill burr.
Hey,
enter Promo code bill burr all capital letters,
by the way,
no space.
All right.
D s t l d genes.
That's the longest,
most complicated name ever for a pair of fucking genes.
The problem with jeans is that they're really good pairs cost between two and
300 bucks to have you hug your fucking ball big there easily.
And the bargain brands just fall apart and look terrible.
Those are the gap ones where you've got all those red next to in the line
dancing and uh,
you know,
but you know,
they're broads,
they,
they haven't led them out of the house yet.
They're just making pies and shit.
They walked from the stove to the fucking silt.
That's it.
All right.
D s Tld pronounced distilled.
Okay.
I didn't know that.
Has Revolutionize,
revolutionize.
Can you tell him like fucking three tequilas and this is like fucking like nine
hours past the podcast.
I didn't realize how to do this shit has revolutionized the fashion industry by
creating timeless luxury grade denim.
I didn't know there was such a thing.
So you get genes that would cost you hundreds of dollars starting a at 65 bucks.
Oh,
I know what you're saying.
It's like diesel jeans except as 65 bucks.
Hey everybody.
How do they do it?
How does that work?
Mia,
by refusing to work with department stores in retail middlemen,
there's no markup,
no bullshit,
just great jeans at unbelievable prices.
Just go to distill.com d s t l d.com find the perfect pair with the perfect fit
to hug your fucking balls yet support your taint and keep your ass lifted and
your spirits high.
They'll ship them to you for free and guarantee the fit or we'll send you a new
pair till they are perfect.
See for yourself why a list celebrities had been spotted in magazines like vogue
and doubt.
Fuck that whole sentence.
They got paid to do it.
They're not going to a podcast to find out where they get their genes that are
out there.
There a list.
Celebrities,
they get genes helicoptered in.
Even seedless celebrities like me.
Why?
Why did you write that shit?
What am I fucking,
Kathy Griffin went the Dick.
I have a little more self esteem than that.
I got a pair of raw denim.
No I don't and it fits amazing.
I've never put them on.
This still does.
The only place in the u s you can get the weight of denim for this price.
Now what the natural indigo look,
they,
they're going to fade beautifully and last for years.
Independent in defense of these fucking people.
These fucking people who advertise,
they always ask the podcast or can we send you some free shit?
And I always say,
no,
I don't want the shit.
So they gave me the copy,
like they gave me the jeans and I walked around them and said,
Ooh,
my balls feels tremendous.
I have enough jeans.
I'm a sweat pants guy.
You know what I mean?
I don't want to work.
I like my balls dangling in the wind.
I like thinking about nothing and I like boozing anyways,
but,
but you don't need to be a celebrity or I have a stylist or even pay $100 to
look at it.
Amazing.
Distilled starts at 65 bucks.
Half of how you look is how your pants fit,
so get your genes right.
Just go to the [inaudible] dot com slash bird right now,
get $10 off your first parents.
So now he gets,
it's 55 bucks.
That's still.com DST ld.com/burr for $10 off right now.
Five levers,
five letters.
All right.
Delta,
Sierra,
Tango,
Lima,
delta.com/burma is there.
Only one left.
Oh Jesus to left.
All right,
Helen.
He lives.
Who knows?
All right.
You're your unique course.
Everybody is your face doesn't look like anybody else.
That doesn't mean your special though.
I don't want to fucking rain on your parade,
but what?
What are you doing with the special face?
I've never seen anybody look like you.
What are you doing with that face?
Let's get back to the copy.
You don't walk like everyone else talk like everyone else or sleep like anyone
else.
So why is your mattress man one size fits all?
I don't know cause it's fucking easy because it truly customized mattress will
only cost you five to 10,000 bucks until now.
Now,
now go to hell.
Helix,
sleep.com answer a few simple questions.
You Dope.
And then they'll run a three dimensional bio Canaliculi model of your body
through the proprietary algorithms they develop with your help with the help of
the world's leading arrogant nomics and biochem.
I'll stop with the big fucking words.
We get it.
You've got a laptop.
The result,
the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept done.
Heloc helix,
customers support a 30 customers report,
a 30% improvement.
And overall sleep quality.
I don't understand that.
You're asleep.
How the fuck do you know whether it's going good enough?
You know,
what are your dreams better?
before I had this mattress,
I dreamed I was sleeping with Tina.
Yeah,
others.
And then when I got this mattress,
I was fucking Rihanna.
Let's get back to the copy and for a couple,
and for couples,
they customize each side of the mattress.
Your mattress arrives at your door in about a week in shipping is 100% free.
That's everyone from GQ
magazines to Forbes.
Evidentaly.
They're all talking about how he looks.
He looks sleep.
You have 100 nights to try it out,
gross,
and if you don't like it,
they'll pick it up for free,
disgusting and give you 100% refund.
No questions asked.
Do they burn it at the end of your driveway?
Go to helix,
dotcom slash.
Burn and get 50% off your order.
That's he looks Dotcom.
Slash.
Bird.
He likes Helux,
sleep.com/burr Oh and Mike.
Wow,
one of my favorites.
Okay,
one of my absolute flavors.
Everybody.
Here we go.
It's souls.
Hey,
hey,
are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Hey,
oh hey,
do you know where to go?
Posting your job in one place isn't enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post all your jobs.
At the top job site that even exist.
And now you can with ziprecruiter.com you can post your job to 100 plus job
sites,
including social media networks like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click.
Find candidates in any sin city,
any industry nationwide.
Just post and watch your qualified candidates roll into zip.
Easy to use interface.
No juggling emails or calls to your office.
Quickly scan candidates,
rate them and hire the right person fast man.
Find out why ZipRecruiter has been used by over 1 million fucking businesses.
And right now my listeners can post jobs on ZipRecruiter for free by going to
zip.
Yeah.
[inaudible] dot com slash burped.
That's ziprecruiter.com/burr.
Um,
one more time.
Try It for free by going to ziprecruiter.com/burr.
Um,
some,
I feel like I skipped like the last three sentences of that.
I don't know why I didn't know why I still had advertising to do.
That's the end of the advertising.
Please enjoy the music that follows and a some clips from a wonderful podcast
from some fucking podcast a year going by.
All right.
Go fuck yourselves.
Feel Bella check is the greatest of all time.
You know what?
I know it.
Even if you live in New York City,
all right?
God bless you when you futon,
go fuck yourself.